[Musique]
ça fait du tort
vous êtes présent
sans jamais nous ap
depuis le début
vous m'avez soutenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'est elle à nouveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cette pré sort
votre canapé soja benouza paix depuis le
début pour m'avaient soutenu
[Musique]
personne ne pense
l affaire
et sans visa
m
les frais
hm question coquine la partie j'ai de
suite la question qu'au lac et sur la
question atout france a même plus où
france ô combien ont déjà fait crac crac
badaboum
[Rires]
merci d'avoir répondu marine face à
l'anarchie ça va vous sinon ça va je
vous ai vu chez bourdin ce matin
benj s'était entre-temps h ces questions
alors un superbe à nous ça va et ça va
bonhommes à londres on arrive à joindre
les deux bouts coin voilà à quoi bon bah
je vous embrasse marley no 6 bonjour
estelle bonjour c'est patrick patrick
bruel j'aimerais savoir s'il était
possible de réserver une table pour ce
soir peut-être c'est vrai sur le match
j'avais j'étais venu avec qui adorent le
chef exactement pensera ce serait pour
ce soir bon une table ça peut-être 5 6
ou peut-être sept ou huit
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais comment ça peut partir en
cacahuète
pour jean claude et je compte c'est quoi
cette ligne de folie là c'est quoi cette
classe à tes beaux gosses toi prête et
jean t-shirt écoulée marquée que le
paquet vraiment marre a tué sa mère nom
de chaque ou danton
[Musique]